the Senate may have voted down those
articles of impeachment this week but
that's not the end of the story first
stop ladies and gentlemen let me present
some new articles to House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi here they are the articles of
incompetence article 1 everything you do
to try and hurt the president
you hate blows up in your face just as
the Senate shut down your impeachment
fast president Trump's approval ratings
hit a record high and it's obvious why
while you spent the last three years
working to reverse the will of the
American people the president spent the
last three years working to help the
American people
the results are piling up a phase-one
china trade deal us mca tax cuts 2.0 in
the works and yet another strong jobs
report on Friday more Americans working
earnings rising second article of
incompetence Iowa your caucus Fiasco
showed and I think this calls for a
classic British expression at this point
you people couldn't organize a piss-up
in a brewery aside from the dark money
and their Clinton connections behind the
whole debacle the serious point as The
Wall Street Journal brilliantly put it
is this the party that promises
technocratic management of American
health care energy and finance prove
less able to tally votes even than the
ancient Athenians article 3 you can't
control your temper for 3 years we've
put up with your endless lectures about
civility and upholding democratic norms
and then at the State of the Union you
put on this embarrassing petulant stunt
article 4 even when they're trying to
deceive the voters that Democrats are
incompetent Elizabeth Warren never stops
raising the alarm about climate change
and raging about the billionaires put
those things together and what do you
get
private jets gas guzzling plutocrat
playthings you'd never catch the
people's green champion on one of those
right so ok just watch this there she is
Elizabeth Warren she's on a private jet
she suddenly realizes she's being filmed
so she literally tries to hide behind an
aide these lefties are so incompetent
they can't even cover
their own hypocrisy so today on behalf
of a nation crying with laughter at the
Democrats with great sadness and of
course prayerfulness I sign these four
articles of incompetence there they are
Nancy I can send you this pen if you
like and here's the other way that
Wednesday's impeachment vote shouldn't
be the end of the story for years the
alleged abuse of power and corruption by
President Trump has been investigated
over and over and over again but what
about the alleged Biden corruption not a
single investigation sure you know how
senators Grassley Johnson and others
pushing for a review of hunter Biden's
overseas dealings but where have they
been we've been laying out the Biden
corruption for nearly a year hunter
hired by a Ukraine energy company while
his dad was directing taxpayer dollars
towards Ukraine's energy sector you can
see he's guilty
from the way Joe Biden reacts when
challenged on it do you think it was
wrong for him to take that position
knowing that it was really because that
company wanted access to you well that's
not true you're saying things you do not
know what you're talking about no one
said that who said that what it's just
one of those things where people think
well that seems kind of sleazy why would
he have that job if not for his who his
father was
he's a very bright guy I guess the
question I'm kind of asking is was it
right as a parent yeah yeah well he said
he regretted having done it speak for
himself
it's a grown man he says speak for
himself
yes exactly in the witness chair hunter
Biden tell us your expertise in Ukraine
your expertise in energy in 2014 when
you were hired by Purisima when you were
wandering around a crack den in Los
Angeles in 2016 while on the Bur yzma
board was that on behalf of the company
how about Joe can you speak for yourself
to how much US taxpayer money went to
Burr yzma while your son was on the
board and use
billions of dollars to Ukraine's energy
industry you said you didn't know about
your son's ties to Purisima but last
year he said he told you so who's lying
you or your son and while we're talking
about your Ukraine corruption how about
your China corruption remember this so
Joe China
what exactly did Han to do in Beijing in
December 2013 when you took him there on
Air Force two was it a coincidence that
less than two weeks later his company
signed an exclusive and unprecedented
billion dollar deal with a state-owned
Bank of China any connection to the fact
that you went soft on China just at that
moment and still to this day say they're
no competition it doesn't stop with
hunter does it Joe corruption is a whole
family business for the Biden's as Peter
Schweitzer documents and his new book
profiles in corruption your son-in-law
Howard crime was the chief medical
officer at a tiny company called start
up health that went on to receive
unprecedented access and support from
the Obama administration your brother
James with no experience in construction
was hired as an executive vice president
at the construction company the hill
stone group less than three weeks after
the firm's president visited the White
House in the following months hill stone
was awarded tens of millions of dollars
worth of government contracts your
brother Frank with no experience in real
estate or Costa Rica got lucrative
real-estate deals in Costa Rica just
months after you happened to visit the
country's vice president and his another
Costa Rica coincidence for Frank Biden
their government did a deal with Franks
energy company of course he had no
experience in energy either on a solar
project that received a US taxpayer
backed six point five million dollar
loan oh wait there's a Frank Biden
Caribbean coincidence too in June 2014
as vice president you announced the
launch of a new program to boost
financing for Caribbean energy projects
later on the Obama administration
announced a forty seven and a half
million dollar loan to build a 20
megawatt solar facility in Jamaica guess
who ended up signing a deal to build a
20 megawatt solar facility in Jamaica
the
himself Frank Biden it's like Frank is
the new hunter and it looks like you Joe
Biden and the whole corrupt snouts in
the trough Biden family hunter Frank
James Howard for decades you've grifted
taxpayers while pretending to be just a
regular blue-collar family what a joke
so here is the question tonight what the
hell do we have to do to get the Biden
corruption investigated for three years
president Trump has his administration
blocked and probed and hounded but
nothing on the other side that is not
fair
that is not justice that is not the rule
of law but the law of the swamp and the
king of the swamp is Joe Biden
so as impeachment comes to an end let
the investigation of Biden begin